well it's weird now when you hit a
certain age you have a HomeTown but you
feel so far removed like I've been
living Los Angeles for 15 years which
feels insane to me that I was I've been
in La I'm so much longer than I lived in
New York or or anywhere else in my life
I still don't know any I don't I can't
go anywhere without GPS I don't know how
to get anywhere did you
um someone asked me the other day
because I first came to LA in 1985 and
someone said wait a minute there was no
GPS what did you do and I said we had
something called This is Where I sound
like no I had to use that yeah I was
born and raised here yeah so I
remembered I had a Thomas guide which
was like this big kind of almost phone
book thing and I'd be on the phone not a
cell phone but just a telephone and
someone would say yeah we're having a
Super Bowl at my house it's in you know
Sherman Oaks oh okay that's in the
valley where are you I'm at 325 you know
West Ridge Lane in uh and I'd say okay
and I'd write that down and then I would
look up the in the back back and would
say Westridge Lane Thousand Oaks page 75
B7 and then it was a grid and then you
would drive I drove I had a 1977 Isuzu
opal what would it looked like they had
I bought it uh obviously used at the
airport and it looked like they had
butchered meat in the back seat
[Laughter]
I went to a wedding uh once and uh my
date for the wedding was Lisa Kudrow
this is when she was doing uh improv and
I was doing improv and we were we were
what we would call friends uh and
and I said hey maybe you should do a
sitcom name that someday and I'd like a
piece of it well someone forgot my piece
anyway
um yeah I drove her to This Bar Mitzvah
in that car and she got in the car and I
saw her physically Blanche it was such a
terrible car but then she was a good she
like got in and didn't say anything
about it and I know she thought oh he
murdered someone in the back seat and
now well there was we're going to be
fair there was butchered meat in the
back seat of your car it's not a bad
place to keep butchered meat keep an eye
on it no one can steal it the but it is
crazy to think that you would go into
tomsky be like okay Sherman Oaks it's
a25 page 76 and then you would have to
then find the route from where you were
to then be like I guess I'll I guess
I'll take the one out but and then you
did you just hold it in because when I
first came to La we were it was pre-gps
would you like hold it in your lap I
would keep yeah you'd hold it in your
lap or you'd keep it sort of like uh you
know in the in the space between the two
c seats or I would keep mine often I was
never I was hardly ever driving anybody
I was usually alone so yeah it's been a
butcher van yeah
was no no chick magnet in my car uh but
um yeah you would do that and I remember
very clearly the first time I got GPS
someone told me about it and I uh it was
in a rental car I was using and so I
didn't know where my friend Greg Daniels
was and he said I met this address and I
punched it in and I just followed the
directions I don't know what year this
would be but I follow the directions and
then it said turned here right and it
said your destination is on your left
and I turned to my left and Greg was
standing right there and I swear to God
I looked up and was like Jesus is real
this is I mean it was such a profound
insane experience yeah it was like it
was a product like a tom tom or one of
those like things that you put on the
car yeah yeah and I I was blown away
that that was possible and my kids
that's just the reality they know
they've had that their whole life you
really don't ever learn how to go
anywhere I know I and I've largely since
I've lived in L.A there's been some
version of GPS and I've like literally
never learned how to drive anywhere in
Los Angeles I don't trust myself to
drive anywhere are you a good driver a
lot of New Yorkers are terrible drivers
yeah I'm a fine driver I'm like not
great I'm not a guy yeah I've never been
like I don't know I think it's weird
when people like I'm a good driver I'm
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
you're a good driver yeah yeah it's like
you're in the Indy 500 yeah you know
what I mean those guys are like I speed
a lot that's what I feel like they're
telling me uh but I yeah I I grew up uh
driving since yeah I mean I was ever
since I was like six I think I've been
driving legally
you're just you should be a pretty good
driver I'm a pretty good driver I I mean
I if it's like a tiny plastic car with a
and if there's an adult pushing you yeah
yeah behind slowly yeah on a level
surface then you're a good job pretty
good driver if I can steer it